8 news now reporter sally jaramillo was
also there and tells us why they say
this was really a historic day sally
denise the va of southern nevada was the
first
hospital to receive the first patient
with covert 19.
today not only one but two doctors
received the vaccine
and they said they come a long way
now doctors say their these past nine
months have been exhausting and
challenging as you can imagine
when the first vaccine was given there
were emotional
infectious deceased physician dr jason
daisley was one of the doctors who
received it
he's excited to talk to others who have
the vaccine hesitancy
so that they can assist through the
process and understand
why the vaccine is a step in the right
direction
why are we getting it is it just that
we're just kind of have to do it or
something it's really more that we
understand the science behind it
we also look at all those that are
scientists that are doing the peer
review certainly we have questions
about a lot of things regarding the
vaccine but we don't have doubt
the v.a send out service to staff before
the vaccine arrive at first 40 percent
said
they will get the vaccine but over time
that number increased to 55 percent
now they do expect those numbers to
continue to increase
reporting live in north las vegas sally
jaramillo 8 news now
sally we know that a lot of people are
hesitant about getting the vaccine
what are some of the misconceptions
about it that you heard from doctors
today what's the most common one
well denise yeah there's many
misconceptions and amongst the main one
that the vaccine has pieces of the virus
so that would end up giving people the
coronavirus
doctors say that is not true back to you
sally thanks for that tonight well if
you think you may have been exposed to
covid19 or exposed to someone who has
coveted is so important to get tested
a testing is available here's some more
locations at mojave high school
tomorrow and friday it runs from 8 am to
12 pm also friday you can get tested
at the heritage park senior facility
that is near downtown henderson testing
there is 8 a.m until
12 30 p.m and we do have a full list of
all the times and locations over on
eightnewsnow.com